they don't make many mistakes they've
had a few penalties they just say
perfect going against Bill Belichick
this is you know somebody who I have
much respect for probably talk to me
after the game you know it's just a
small slice of thirteen minutes
yesterday from ohto Beckham jr. meeting
with reporters and I'd say from that 13
minutes Chris there was probably three
or four minutes where he praises the
Patriots talks about the Patriots talks
about playing for the Patriots at least
that was something he wanted to do in
the past and it it reminded me a little
bit of a postgame press conference from
Randy Moss when he was playing for the
Vikings the second time around they lost
to the Patriots in Foxborough Moss laid
it on thick about the Patriots and the
Vikings cut in the next day not not that
the Browns are gonna do that but but if
you watch and listen to the full 13
minutes and and you pay attention to how
many times it comes up in the praise
it's very nonchalant by Beckham like he
doesn't realize it could be a problem by
being that lavish in your praise because
you have a head coach you have a
quarterback who may be listening the
same man maybe he wants to play in New
England but I came away from the 13
minutes thinking maybe this guy wants to
play in New England well III don't think
there's like any doubt about that I
think there's a great respect there of
course there's a lot of players that
have that type of respect for New
England and especially you know on a
Wednesday where he's probably already
watched some film and got the game plan
he's watching what they're doing and
he's going damn I mean I haven't seen
teams do this and well they're doing
some crazy stuff so you know it's even
more on your mind in that aspect but I
think there's been you know as I've
reported and said what was that last
spring or whatever I think there was
always mutual interest from both sides
that maybe one day this could happen I
was led to believe that as you know and
so I think there is affection where the
Patriots have an ultimate of respect for
Odell Beckham jr. and if they could have
acquired them via trade they would have
tried to and I think Odell Beckham jr.
is kind of letting us know that he would
have loved it for that to have happened
as well and I think that's where this
hang comes yeah it's not just would have
loved it to happen I think that they'd
embedded within everything he said
yesterday is the unmistakable whiff that
he would still like it to happen in the
future
especially if the Cleveland experiment
continues on its current path of two and
four through six games and two and five
staring them in the face because they
play the Patriots in Foxborough on
Sunday and and let's let's continue that
conversation on the other side of these
comments from Beckham yesterday talking
about his desire at least in the past if
not in the future to play for the
Patriots serious I think two three years
ago there was speculations and all that
I was going on and I was willing and
ready to go over there at any point in
time and that was always a dream of mine
to play Tom Brady like Tom Brady and
Belichick but for me when I said I
wanted to be part of I wanted to turn
this into the Patriots organization and
it's a one is about winning but it's
about the way that they go about and how
everything is precise and everything is
it's just it's perfectly it feels good
to win it feels good to succeed and
that's what I meant by morning to be
like them you know I don't I don't know
how to be like them because I've never
been open I've never experienced any of
it but you know Tom and I talked you
know for two three years like Amen
happens okay
so here's the thing how long does he
have to be in Cleveland to realize that
what we have here isn't what they have
there yeah and I'd still kind of like to
be there because this ain't there why
yeah well you're right I mean he doesn't
have to be in Cleveland very long to
realize that there's nothing that can
compare to there and there being the New
England Patriots they're there on
another level from the rest of the NFL
and all phases of their organization
they are the standard in every way I
mean so and I think just with those
comments there yeah
tells you there was some fording going
on between the Patriots in Odell Beckham
jr. and we know just from this year
especially the Patriots are not scared
of personalities and trying to bring
them in and make it work and whatever
else but you know at the end of the day
guys who really love the sport and that
are really into doing the things that it
takes to win and all that you're gonna
respect the Patriots to a degree and of
course everybody wants to play for them
to a degree as well it's like the
Yankees you know when they're in their
prime everybody wants to be on that
stage all the time and New England is
the stage right now and all the
primetime games and then the stage of oh
what's the playoffs and that's patriot
time and then it's the Super Bowl and
that's patriot time as well and those
are the moments players live for and
that's why a guys like Odell Beckham jr.
have a lot of affection for the
franchise in general and remember he
made a stir back in May when comments
emerged from an interview with GQ where
he said he wants to make the Browns into
the new Patriot and that created a
couple of days worth of conversation and
criticism and scrutiny and you know I
want to win multiple championships here
in Cleveland and the thing is at some
point he's gonna realize it's just not
going to happen right and he gets
frustrated very easily he surely didn't
expect the Browns to be two and four
he's not doing as much as he thought he
was going to do he's not getting the
ball the way he thought he was gonna get
the ball and even though he doesn't I
mean when he says I don't know what it
takes to be like that yeah right that
tells me he's yet to experience anything
Kristen in his heart and in his mind
reminds him of New England and yes as
you said no one else is New England but
if this is what he wants I mean I can't
imagine that there weren't members of
the Browns organization whether it was
coach Freddie kitchens quarterback Baker
Mayfield ownership GM whoever who
listened to those comments yesterday and
said I don't think this guy really wants
to be here well I don't know if I agree
with that I just think they're gonna
come away going man he's got a lot of
respect and loves the Patriots I wonder
if there was more to that relationship
than maybe we we all realize which I
think we all realized that there was
more to that relationship but but to
like what your
saying you know again you know players
say oh I'd love to go there be there you
know you gotta be there to experience it
it's a different place and that's why
they are New England - you know a lot of
guys don't know what they don't know
until you go up there and get a taste of
it and it's not always for everybody
because yeah personalities are not
always welcome there if you cross the
line I should say you know there's
personalities up there but you also got
to have a little blend of like no you're
a cog in a bigger picture of the Patriot
Machine here that's very important and
you got to check your ego at the door
from that aspect too let alone hey
they're gonna coach you and ride your
heart and hold you accountable every day
and it doesn't matter who it is you know
that's the Patriot Way the Patriot Way
is on April 27th they prepare just the
same as they do on January 23rd getting
ready for the AFC Championship game
that's what's brilliant about the
Patriots and that's really where they
win a lot of their competitions verse
the rest of the NFL it's already in the
books before they even play the lot of
these teams I think back to 2010 when
Randy Moss was becoming kind of a
problem in New England so they dumped
him onto the Vikings for a third-round
pick before it really became an issue
three weeks later Moss goes back to New
England and gets a taste of what he has
walked away from or what he was traded
away from and that's when he made his
comments after the game and that's when
the Vikings cut him loose and I
mentioned that again because it's one
thing for Beckham to muse about what New
England is like as he gets ready to play
them but he's gonna go there and he's
gonna you know what's he gonna say after
the game about the Patriots I just think
this bears watching the trade window is
still open yep I don't think the Browns
would let him go at this point I think
they would at least want the package
that they got for him in the first place
so they can say we are where we would
have been even if we'd never acquired
him but man it just it we've seen
crazier things happen and would it be
crazy if next Tuesday afternoon Odell
Beckham jr. ends up being traded to the
Patriots well it would be crazy I mean I
don't think there's any way that it
happens I mean I still think the the
Browns are trying to build something
here for the future
and everybody's scared to send people
like Odell Beckham jr. to the Patriots
anyways or do business with the Patriots
because they need to be scared that it's
all gonna get thrown in your face and
all of a sudden he's gonna lead the NFL
and receiving and touchdowns and then it
makes your organization look worse from
that standpoint - but hey there's
something special about New England I
mean there's just no denying that they
haven't lucked into 19 years of
dominance here its details its
preparation it's situational football
expertise and you know to speak to your
Randy Moss thing and that whole year in
2010 I was with Randy Moss after he got
cut from that Minnesota team for that
second time around because then he
signed with the Tennessee Titans
we had many conversations on the
sidelines during practice of him gushing
about New England and even at the time
going like you know this isn't the way
New England does things here and I
wanted to be yeah I mean I know I played
for Josh McDaniels I hadn't been in New
England at that point but I realized
that just through my years of my dad
talking about it and everything like
that and yet Randy Moss I think he got
addicted to the professionalism the
detail and the desire to win that that
makes it so great up in New England as
well
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports